hello everyone all defensive super
tournaments are over so before the
candidates start we have plenty of time
to explore some old classics as that's
where the real fun lies here I said I
would analyze this game quite some time
ago plus it was suggested by a lot of
people this is the game from the very
strong New York tournament of 1918 and
like I said in those days every
tournament was strong and every
tournament was famous it was supposed to
be and an eighth player double
round-robin but in the end one of the
players got sick so they had to make it
a six player two round-robin and already
in the first round of this very strong
tournament we have the famous game host
a row kappa blanka playing against Frank
James Marshall a lot of you probably
already heard about Frank Marshall
either through his variation to Marshall
attack a variation of the rule opus or
maybe you've heard about his famous game
against Stefan Levitsky the American
Beauty where according to legend people
started throwing gold coins on the board
after seeing Marshalls amazing move if
you haven't I will put a link in the
description below I also made a video
about that game so feel free to check it
out in that game I also said a bit more
information about Frank Marshall so I'm
not going to be introducing him in this
video so let's see this game it's quite
an amazing game and Capablanca opens
with efore and according to legend of
this game Frank Marshall actually saved
this variation his famous Marshall
attack for eight years he didn't want to
play it against anyone and he was saving
it for a worthy opponent and who is the
worst the opponent if not the great
Cuban Jose roll kappa blanka and now
there are some stories that some people
already played this idea but there is no
way of telling if marshall ever heard
about these games or if Capablanca ever
heard about these games so as far as
we're concerned this is the first time
capablanca sees the Marshall attack by
Frank Marshall himself and it's very
interesting how he deals with it over
the board while the clock is ticking so
II five we have night to have 396 and
Bishop to b5
Daru Lopez a6 Murphy's defense brush up
to a four Knight to f6 and here we have
castles Bishop to e7 now rook to e1 b5
Bishop has to go to big b3 marshal
castles and this is the position here
now it's known that if you go c3 you're
inviting the marshal attack if you're
not comfortable playing against the
marshal attack you can play a four this
prevents the marshal attack or even h3 I
will I will come back to this later if
you want to see why why this stops the
marshal attack
so ac3 a couple of month this although
he never actually faced the marshal
attacks so he's not inviting it but this
is the first time in history someone is
playing the marshal attack in this game
now in New York in 1918 here marshal
place is famous d5 and this is the
variation he's been saving for eight
years as the story goes so each
character son d5 Knight captures on d5
Knight captures and e5 of course Knight
captures rook captures and here we have
Knight to f6 now it's considered
stronger to play pawn to c6 defending
the knight on d5 but in Marshall's
original preparation Knight to f6 was
the idea and here kappa blanka
immediately plays rook to e1 he doesn't
want to wait for Bishop to d6 and he
wants to get that h3 pawn ready as soon
as possible so better up to d6 we have
h3 and it this seemingly stops ideas
like 90 to g4 but this is actually what
marshal planned so he plays Knight to g4
now and already you have to take a lot
of things into consideration first of
all can you capture the night well let's
try if you play H captures on g4 you get
Queen to h4 now with some with some
terrible threats of Bishop captures on
g4 Queen to h2 check is coming Bishop to
h2 is possible a lot of things to
consider
so rook to e4 not allowing the bishop to
capture the g4 pawn also making room for
for the king
sort of an escape route if needed so
Queen to h2 check King to f1 Queen to h1
check
King Torito and now comes Queen captures
on g2 attacking the rook on e4 d3
defending it but now comes Bishop
captures on g4 rook captures Queen
captures you have to move and this is
this is pretty terrible for black his
King is wide open I need to the rooks
are coming into the game it's considered
to be a much better position for black
so after this Knight to g4 Capablanca
didn't capture the night but of course
he didn't know this this wasn't known
theory at the time he played Queen to f3
this is considered to be the best move
and of course capablanca found it over
the board here Queen to h4 and now again
there is a question can you capture the
knight now while the Queen is already on
f3 well let's see if you play egg aah
characters on g4 now now we get Bishop
to h2 check and here you have the option
of going maybe King to h1 or King to f1
let's strike into h1 if King to h1 is
played then you get Bishop to f4 check
this is very important as it as it
prevents the King from reaching III and
also it prevents the Queen from eyeing
at the f7 square so after the King moves
okay you can also block it with the
Queen but if you play Queen to h3 you
lose immediately after Queen captures on
F to add this attacks the rook and after
rook moves and I will get a rope to e8
and there is no defense against rook to
e1 check and mate so instead of playing
Queen to h3 you have to go into g1 but
now Queen Queen h2 check King f1 Queen
h1 check King to e2 and now rook to e8
check King b3 and now rook captures on
e1 Queen characters on f4 and now Queen
to f1 check if you go King to c2 you get
rook captures on c1 this is checkmate
and if instead of King to see to you try
something like King to d4 then I mean
your king is on d4 simply Bishop to e6
preventing all ideas Whitehead on the f7
square
and white white really doesn't have
anything to play
he can't develop any of the pieces but
he has to if he wants to at least play
this game so after let's say night a3
now you can play Bishop captures pawn
captures and I'll simply capture on c1
rook captures Queen captures and now
it's actually black was up in material
you're of the exchange and also this
Knight is stranded on a3 can't go
anywhere so a winning position for black
so that's the idea if you capture it and
after this Bishop to h2 check the king
who goes to h1 another idea you can try
a skink to f1 but King to f1 also
doesn't work because Bishop captures on
g4 and after Queen to e4 you get Bishop
to f4 problem is you can't capture the
bishop or anything because Queen to h1
is checkmate in 1 the bishop is covering
v2 square and after g3 there is Queen to
h2 now G captures on f4 and now Bishop
to h3 check only movies Peter you move
the Queen and lose the game or you have
to play King to e2 and after you're
going to eat you then comes rook to e8
and you lose the Queen and the game so a
lot of things to consider here and you
can see how well prepared Frank Marshall
was for this game so after Queen h4
kappa blanka doesn't capture the night
instead he goes d4 and e4 is a crucial
move when playing against the Marshall
attack especially in an old variation
like this because it will allow one move
that kappa blanka also found on the
board over the board I will not tell you
now which move it is but you will see it
in this game it's quite a move so here
we have Knight captures on f2 and again
Marshall poses a lot of problems for
kappa blanka here can you capture it ok
can you capture the night if you play
Queen captures on f2 then you get Bishop
to h2 check and I've played a lot of
games especially in blitz and the people
people often can make a mistake of
the idea is Bishop 2h to check but some
people play Bishop to g3 immediately
probably people who only started playing
the marshal attack but after playing
Bishop to g3 it looks like you've pinned
the Queen and the rook but if you play
this your entire world will crumble
before your eyes as white plays Queen
captures on f7 this comes with check
unfortunately if you're clicking to h8
Queen captures on f8 is checkmate if you
capture the Queen then rook to e8 and
this is checkmate the rook is pinned
from the bishop on b3
so if Queen captures on f2 then black
has to play Bishop to h2 check first
now if King to h1 you simply capture the
Queen and f2 and if King to f1 now you
play Bishop to g3 and now Queen captures
on f7 doesn't work because rook captures
on f7 comes with check the king is on f1
now so here Queen to d2 probably and
after Bishop captures on h3g captures on
h3 Queen captures on h3 and Queen to g2
you can simply capture capture and
Bishop captures and here you have here
you have a rook for a knight and the
bishop and black is up two pawns
this is considered better for white but
you know finding all of these moves over
the board wasn't wasn't that clear for
kappa blanka so instead after this
Knight captures and I have two couple
Blanca didn't capture instead he played
rook to e2 now attacking the knight with
the Brooke and also not making the rook
anyone a target if the knight ever moves
as the Queen was eyeing that rook anyone
here Bishop to g4 and here again posing
a lot of problems for for kappa blanka
what do you do here well your first your
first idea is HK % g4 but let's try
capturing the knight first for example
if you play Queen captures now then you
get Bishop to g3 Queen to f1 and now
Bishop captures on e2 Queen captures I
need to and now look 88 and it's all
over the rook is coming to e1
there is no stopping this you can
prevented with III Bishop to e3 but now
Queenie for and you can't prevent the
Queen from capturing the bishop on e 393
Queen captures with Czech Queen captures
rook captures and that is that is it
black is up the exchange the pawns are
even but black being up the exchange
winning winning this game easily so
after Bishop to g4 capablanca finds the
strongest reputation over the board and
the strongest is the one you first
thought about probably H captures on g4
but again this took a lot of calculation
and you really have to consider what to
do here here Bishop to h2 check was
played we have King to f1 and now Bishop
to g3 the thread is of course Queen to
h1 checkmate so rook captures an f2 had
to be played we have Queen to h1 check
King to e2 and now Bishop captures on f2
and here if you if you play it's a very
delicate position once again if you play
Queen captures on f2 you get Queen
captures on c1 and now rook to e8 is a
terrible threat now this will be very
bad for black another thing you could do
after Bishop to e2 you could play King
captures on f2 but this would actually
result in a draw after Queen captures on
c1 and let's say Queen to be one now
black has an easy draw as he can always
check the White King on e3 f4 and h6
doesn't matter where the King goes even
if he goes h1 Queen h6 he has to go back
so this is the moment to work up a
Blanca found the amazing move over the
board and this is why I told you why
this d4 move is very important now you
have this Bishop to d2 and this stops
all of white or all blacks threats it
creates a nice escape route for the king
either through d1 to c2 or through d3 to
c2 so a very nice move Bishop to h4 was
played as now there really was a danger
of capturing the bishop now now King can
capture the bishop
or a queen can capture the bishop if you
play rook to e8 check there is no more
any ideas of back rank mates or anything
for example if rocky eight check King
can capture and now Queen can come to
you one and deliver checkmate because
the bishop on d1 is guarding a one so a
very nice move by capablanca definitely
Bishop to h4 getting the bishop out of
harm's way and now Queen to h3 offering
a trade of Queens marshal of course
cannot afford to trade Queen so rook a
to e8 with check kinked d3 and Queen to
f1 again delivering check and King to
see - and capablanca had to see all of
this all of this the Bishop d2 move and
the King walk probably from the start of
the marshal attack probably all the way
from Knight to g4 to be able to play a
game like this here we have Bishop - f2
Queen to f3 simply paralyzing that
Bishop we have Queen to g1 and now
Bishop to d5 c5 now marshal has to open
up lines of attack for his rooks as if
the King stays on c2 and a couple Blanca
manages to develop his pieces it's it's
all over for black D captures on c5
Bishop captures on c5 and b4 now by
capablanca Bishop to d6 and now a 4 we
have a 5 a capture Sun b5 a capture some
b4 and rook to a6 attacking the bishop
on d6 we have Punk actress on c3 Knight
captures and Bishop to b4 but simply b6
here Capablanca starts pushing his past
pawn and this will prove to be deadly
we have Bishop captures Bishop captures
and now h6 making some room for the
black king but kappa blanka simply
pushes b7 here we have rook to e3 and
here Bishop captures on f7 and it's all
over
doesn't matter what black plays
everything loses if you try something
like King to h8 you get rook captures on
h6 this is checkmate the pawn is pinned
from the bishop on c3
if you play if
rook captures Bishop then you get upon
to b8 Queen King has to move and then
you simply play rook captures on h6
would check and it doesn't matter what
you do here if you capture with the pond
and Queen captures is checkmate if you
capture with the king then you get Queen
- h8 King g5 and Queen to h5 this is
checkmate
one other thing after Bishop to f7 you
can try as maybe King to h7 but then you
get Queen if Queen a5 check and after
pawn to g6 simply Queen captures on g5
so after Bishop captures on f7 anything
black does ends in a very nice checkmate
so there is nothing for marshal here to
do other than to resign the game so yeah
this is the famous game where the
marshal attack was used for the first
time by Frank Marshall himself
legend has it like he saved it for 8
years to test it against the word the
opponent and Capablanca passed the test
over the board a lot of players have
been using the marshal attack and it's
been improved Marshalls original version
hasn't been improved and there you know
a lot of ideas for white have been found
and for black also it's quite a quite an
enjoyable opening to play for black as
black always gets a lot of activity but
you know it's it's useful if you play it
against someone who doesn't really know
what he's doing and those people will
probably play an anti Marshall attack
move they will not push c3 like I said
in that position in this position they
will not go c3 inviting the marshal but
if they don't want to learn how to play
the marshal they will simply go H 3 and
a 4 and I said I will say why H 3
doesn't really work because now if you
play d5 and we go into the same
variation of the marshal let's say
Knight of 6 d4 now Bishop to d6 and rook
to e1 now the idea of Knight to g4
doesn't work as you can see although
it's not a very big difference the pawn
is on d4 instead of on d2 and this one
is on c2 instead of on c3 but this
actually makes a whole lot of difference
now after Queen to f3 and Queen to h4
now White has the option of playing rook
to e8 and the reason why he didn't have
this option in the original game where
c3 was played is because now that the d4
has been played this Bishop can come to
d2 and it will it will serve as as a
mean of defense against any rook to e1
threats
so now after Queen captures Queen
captures Knight captures you will have
to capture an FH King Bishop characters
and are simply King captures an f2 and
you are up a piece as white and winning
this game so yeah if you if you enjoy
this you have to be prepared for C 3 H 3
and a 4 as well but you know so it's a
very rich opening so you can you can
brush up on this on your own if you're
interested in the marshal gambit one
other thing I wanted to show you was the
standings after this tournament after
the double round-robin this these are
the standings we have Jose raúl
capablanca in first place with 10 and a
half points out of 12 which 9 wins 0
losses and 3 draws so you know crushing
the field he didn't lose a single game
Frank Marshall got 3rd place here with 6
wins 4 losses in 2 draws and in second
place we have the famous Serbian
Grandmaster Borislav Kostich or as they
call him Bora Kostich also finishing the
tournament without a single loss 6 wins
and 6 draws so although he played a very
nice tournament he couldn't really reach
capablanca would would so many draws but
yeah definitely uh definitely a worthy
result so yeah that's that's the game I
really wanted you to see this game it
featured a lot more lines than my usual
videos because this is a really famous
game and it's the first time it was
played so all of the variations matter
you know as he did really prepare for
this game it's a shame he was but then
again it shows what a great player a
couple
I was so yeah I do hope you enjoyed it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you all for watching
and I will see you soon probably with
another nice classic